-Talk to me about
collaborating with Madonna.
-Oh, my God.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This was at the
Billboard Music Awards.
You crushed it. It was great.
-Thank you, man.
-And how did you even
rehearse this?
Because it was,
like, holograms of like
five different Madonnas
or something.
-Wow. That was crazy.
There was like
one week during rehearsals,
because, actually,
there was the hologram,
so I couldn't see
the Madonnas on the stage.
So I had to learn every step
so I could dance with her,
with the four Madonnas
that I had over there.
-But what were you dancing with?
You just had to fake it?
-Yeah, yeah. I had to fake it.
That was the tough part,
because I couldn't do, like,
a wrong movement,
because I was going to...
-Yeah. But, I mean, and then
the real Madonna came --
-And then the real Madonna came,
and I was confused.
No. I'm kidding.
-She's amazing.
-Yeah, she's amazing.
I love her. I love her so much.
-Dude, she is so -- I've gotten
to know her through the years,
and she's still, to this day,
very mysterious.
A lot of mystique.
-That's the real right word --
very mysterious.
-I remember the first time
I met her.
I go, "Oh, my gosh, Madonna."
I go, "It's an honor
to meet you.
She goes, "Is it?" and left.
Walked away, left.
I go, "What did I say?
Did I say something wrong?"
-Well, actually, yeah,
I said that was the right word,
because when I was
with her in London,
when we were recording the song
that we have together
that is called "Medellín,"
she was like --
I'm from Medellín, Colombia,
Latino.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, when I was there in London,
working with her,
I was in the studio
and I was like,
"What do you think
about these words?
Do you really like it?"
And she was like, "Mm...yeah."
And I'm like, "That's how
you like it or --"
-Yeah, like,
"What does that mean?" Yeah?
-And she was like,
"Mm...you can do better,
but If you want to keep that
word, it's okay."
And I was like, "Wow, okay."
But she's a perfectionist.
She loves having
everything on point,
and that's the great advice
that she gave me once.
So I love her.
And she's Madonna.
She's the queen, man.
-She's the one-and-only.
She's on this as well, right?
-Mm-hmm.
-"Achepe."
-Yeah, "Achepe."
-So, I thought the song
originally was called "HP."
I go, "Oh, it's about a printer.
Great."
What is "Achepe?"
Thank you.
I was like, "Oh, HP. Cool.
It's a branding thing."
But, no, "Achepe."
-"Achepe," but you can
name it "HP," too.
-You can.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-But, dude, already, it's got
300 million hits on YouTube.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's a blessing.
-Can I just say one thing?
You're the youngest ever to hold
first and second spot
simultaneously on
the Latin Billboard chart.
That is amazing.
-Yeah, man.
-You have 20 million
YouTube subscribers.
You have over
42 million Instagram followers.
Wow!
-Yeah. Thank you.
-And now you're about to drop
this new album on Friday,
"11:11."
You're going to go on
a world tour.
-Yeah.
-Are you excited to go on tour?
Do you like going on tour?
-Yeah, I love it.
Actually, I was
missing it a lot,
because I had a a knee surgery
like six months ago,
so I had to stop touring.
But now I feel like --
I'm feeling much better,
I feel, after the surgery.
So, yeah, I can't wait
to go to Mexico.
I'm going to Europe, too.
Then I'm starting my tour
here in the States
in September and October, so
you guys can't miss it.
It's the 11:11 World Tour.
-A lot of good collaborations
on this album.
Ricky Martin I love.
You have Madonna and Nicky Jam.
Is there anyone that you want to
collaborate with
that you haven't?
-Well, actually, yeah, and I
know you're super-close to him.
I need your help, man,
in this one.
-Please --
-Don't, don't.
-Yeah.
-No.
-Justin Timberlake.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I can't call him.
-Oh, my God.
-You want me to call him?
-Oh, please.
You know what?
Where's my phone.
-Yeah, really.
We'll call him right now.
-Please, can you call him
from my phone
so I can save the number,
you know?
-You guys would be great.
You would be fantastic together.
That would just be great.
Justin -- He's watching.
Justin, call Maluma.
This is Gilgigil.
-Gilgigil?
-Gilgigil and Maluma has asked
you a favor. Please.
-Yeah, but I don't know if
you're going to be in the song.
You want to be in the song?
I'm just kidding.
-You know -- Yeah, yeah.
I know you were playing with
me for a second.
Like, "Does he mean it?"
Like, "Oh."
You're just mysterious,
like Madonna. Yeah.
You're gonna perform
"HP" tonight.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, yeah. "HP."
-Thank you for being here.
Thank you for talking to me.
Maluma, everybody!